suivront une craie nous créons vous
créez il change
est ce qu'il ya des artistes parmi vous
ce soir
oui là quelques-uns pourquoi est ce que
vous créez est-ce que vous pensez que
l'art peut changer les choses
moi je crée parce que je rêve je pense
que les choses ne bougent que si l'on
rêve mais ce n'est pas tant l'oeuvre qui
change le monde mais c'est l'élan
qu'elle charrie avec elle ce sont les
interrogations les réflexions qu'elle
suscite
les émotions qu'elles provoquent
alors moi je crée aussi pour
m'interroger pour interroger sur le
monde qui m'entoure
comment agir aujourd'hui à l'heure de
monde où l'homme cedh au totalement
déconnectée de la nature essentielle
comment agir aujourd'hui à l'ère d'un
monde où la cupidité l'avidité humaine
nous ont engouffré dans une impasse
comment agir a l'air d'une planète
malade polluer contaminé déshumanisé
alors je crée pour explorer de nouveau
possible même à l'heure des impossibles
à l'heure où on l'atteint aujourd'hui le
seuil critique de plus de 60 millions de
réfugiés dans le monde nos pouvoirs
politiques de cette planète peine à
trouver des solutions
et humaines pour recueillir ce flot
ininterrompu de migrants mais grands
politiques par le passé aujourd'hui
migrants climatiques et surtout demain
aussi des migrants climatiques
alors c'est vraiment dans ces moments là
des moments critiques comme cela que je
veux m'engager que je veux créer que je
veux inventer des formes artistiques
pour interpeller les esprits mais
surtout toucher au coeur des gens d'une
façon sensible émotionnel alors oui je
veux créer pour mobiliser pour susciter
le dialogue et j'espère inspiré l'action
à l'image de deux artistes dont j'admire
le travail
le premier c'est bruce claque avec un
projet artistique et mémorielles très
fort les hommes debout alors il peint
des hommes des femmes des enfants sur
les façades des murs de sites qui ont
été en lien avec le génocide du rwanda
alors ces hommes debout sont pour moi le
symbole de la dignité humaine qui se
dresse face à la déshumanisation des
génocides leur artiste jr un photographe
qui collent sur les murs des favelas ces
portraits ces regards ces visages de
femmes
c'est comme pour rendre hommage à la
dignité de ces femmes qui ont un rôle
incontournable dans nos sociétés et qui
pourtant sont les premières victimes des
guerres des massacres des viols
alors moi pour créer pour enfanter une
oeuvre
j'ai besoin de me frotter au réel j'ai
besoin d'être au coeur des situations
j'ai besoin d'être imprégné des faits
pour mieux en appréhender tous les
enjeux qu'ils soient globaux on l'a vu
tout à l'heure les réfugiés les
génocides
mais des enjeux très locaux près de chez
moi
c'est comme cela que je me suis
intéressé à l'accélération de la
disparition de la biodiversité sur cette
île alors j'ai observé à l'échelle de ma
petite vie les altérations les
dégradations des milieux naturels je
suis sûr que vous aussi vous l'avez
constaté et les scientifiques que j'ai
rencontré malheureusement confirme la
gravité de la situation
alors c'est au coeur de cette
biodiversité aussi exceptionnel que
fragile que j'ai créé des oeuvres qui
ont temporairement transformé le paysage
mais c'est pour mieux changer le regard
que l'on porte pour mieux changer la
perception du lieu pour voilà aborder
cette question pour la rendre visible
alors je vais vous prendre l'exemple
d'une installation que j'ai planté sur
la place de la victoire peut-être que
certains d'entre vous l'ont vu il ya
deux ou trois ans il faut savoir que la
place par l un des derniers sanctuaires
d'arbres multi centenaire
les sabliers
et bien sûr ces sabliers j'ai posé sur
les troncs des arbres des gares au rouge
c'est vraiment pour signifier cet
étranglement de la ville de
l'urbanisation sur la nature et bien
tout le temps où avec mon équipe j'ai
installé ces gars haut sur la place de
la victoire
mais il y avait des gens qui passaient
par la place qui travaille sur la place
qui habite la place qui sont venus me
voir me questionner certains inquiets de
savoir qu'on n'allait pas couper des
arbres j'espère d'autres juste un
témoignage pour me dire que il avait
oublié qu'ils avaient ces arbres sur la
place et le témoignage le plus touchant
c'est celui d'un vieux monsieur qui
habite sur la place qui est venu vers
moi qui m'a pris par la main et qui m'a
emmené près d'un sablier et qui m'a
montré les impacts de balles qui datait
de 1967 lors de la révolte qu'il y avait
eu sur la place de la victoire et il m'a
raconté l'histoire avec tellement
d'émotion alors oui j'aime ses
interventions dans l'espace public
j'aime créer dans l'espace public
cet espace poétique où tout cela est
possible
vous avez compris ce qui me pousse à
créer tout le vient cette énergie et je
vais vous parler de ce que je fais
quelles formes artistiques j'ai choisi
ou plutôt qui qui m'a choisi d'ailleurs
c'est le land art littéralement l'art du
paysage
c'est à dire créer dehors dans la ville
dans la nature
c'est quelque part pour moi repoussé
aussi les limites
imaginez que la planète devient votre
espace de création et d'inspiration
alors mon travail de land art est pour
moi comme une empreinte que je choisi de
poser dans le paysage mais sans laisser
de traces irréversible les empreintes
comme signes symboles sont assez
récurrent dans mon travail de création
comme vous voyez ici je pose des
empreintes de pieds géante sur les murs
sur le sol dans la terre sur le sable
ces empreintes sont tantôt minéral
végétal picturale mais elles sont
surtout le signe de la trace de l'homme
la trace du passage de l'homme est le
miroir de notre société
alors elles ont été tantôt signe de
liberté d'autrefois mémoire de
l'esclavagé mémoire douloureuse mais
elles sont surtout pour moi aujourd'hui
le signe de l'avidité sans mesure de
l'homme a exploité à consommer les
ressources que la nature a mis tant de
temps à constituer il y a quelques
années de cela mon chemin croise le
cinéma belle aventure je laborde
par la forme documentaire alors c'est
pour moi une nouvelle forme de création
une nouvelle corde à mon arc et qui
cette fois va puiser dans l'intimité de
mon histoire personnelle pour toucher
l'universalité des préoccupations de la
société alors les le premier sujet qui
kim a ajouté on va dire et même super g
je dirais c'est la question du genre
comme vous l'avez vu
j'ai un prénom typiquement masculins guy
qui m'a été donnée par mon père bien
avant ma naissance et ce prénom je les
portais comme un fardeau
jusqu'à ce que je fasse ce premier film
mauvais genre alors oui j'ai eu envie de
le dire
mon père j'ai eu envie de comprendre ce
déchirement intérieur qui m'habitait
quel était le bon genre celui que la
nature m'a donné le féminin ou celui que
mes parents ont projeté le masculin
alors dans le film je suis allé à la
rencontre des gens qui comme moi avaient
des prénoms de genre opposé pour
comprendre comment il le vivait mais
pour la suite de l'histoire je vous
invite à voir le film
ensuite un autre sujet qu'on pourrait
presque qualifier de l'existentiel qui
m'a taraudé là aussi vous verrez pour
des raisons aussi à ses personnels au
départ la question de la mémoire
que nous reste-t-il lorsque la mémoire
s'en est allé
alors je suis allé dans une maison de
retraite
j'ai côtoyé les pensionnaires pendant
quelque temps j'ai choisi trois femmes
nonagénaire atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer comme ma mère et donc chaque
jour je conversais avec elle tous les
après midi
chaque conversation était unique
chaque fois chaque jour on partageait
l'instant présent alors comme dit goethe
l'esprit ne regarde ni en avant ni en
arrière le présent seul est notre
bonheur alors c'était une belle leçon
mais elle m'a apaisé
l'année dernière j'ai tenté d'explorer
un sujet que je considère être un tabou
social c'est celui de la non maternité
dans une société comme la nôtre où
l'enfant est le marqueur de
l'accomplissement sociale de la femme
alors à travers ce film poème que
j'appelais la montée des eaux
j'ai voulu à la fois témoigner mais
surtout interpellé
chacun d'entre nous quel regard nous
portons sur ces femmes dans notre
société qui n'ont pas d'enfant
tout cela montre à quel point notre
chemin de vie notre parcours détermine
nos choix pour ma part ça déterminé mon
art danse à la fois c'est pratique et
voilà tous ces sujets qui m'habite
alors mon parcours lui il a été on va
dire très conventionnel et conformiste à
ses débuts imprégné de valeurs
excellence travail
j'ai fait une grande école j'ai
travaillé dans la finance
tout ça pour faire plaisir à mes parents
j'ai écouté ma raison et non mon coeur
jusqu'à ce que je travaille dans un lieu
culturel une scène nationale et là j'ai
côtoyé les artistes au quotidien eh bien
tous les spectacles que j'ai eu toutes
les créations que j'ai vu naître les
échanges que j'ai eus m'ont transformés
ont changé ma vision du monde mon
rapport à l'autre j'étais totalement
fasciné par le pouvoir de l'art à dire
émouvoir a changé à humaniser le monde
et d'ailleurs c'est une oeuvre majeure
pas je considère comme tel
une oeuvre littéraire le cahier d'un
retour au pays natal d'aimé césaire et
bien cette oeuvre a été le déclencheur a
révélé à réveiller en moi
ce désir profond enfouis de devenir
artiste
et c'est une pièce que j'ai vu qui a été
magnifiquement interprété par jacques
martial
mais ce qui a déclenché cet acte de
devenir artiste
c'est paradoxalement l'événement le plus
douloureux de mon existence
le décès de ma mère parce que là tout
s'est écroulé
un chaos et à ce moment là la seule
issue que j'ai entrevu a été de faire de
l'art ma vie ma passion j'ai tout
abandonné
du jour au lendemain pour vivre ce rêve
totalement intensément et si cette vie
d'artiste que je vis aujourd'hui d'une
façon pleine et entière
et cette vie d'artiste me comble
vraiment malgré les difficultés que vous
pouvez imaginer
malgré le contexte complexe difficile
dans lequel nous vivons
mais cette liberté chèrement acquise je
considère que c'est une chance
c'est peut-être le plus beau cadeau que
la vie m'est donnée et surtout le plus
beau cadeau que je me sois offert à moi
même alors depuis chaque jour j'essaie
de faire mienne cette magnifique phrase
de gandhi soit le changement que tu veux
voir dans le monde
merci